Hello world,
it's Saroj and today we're going to
build a machine learning model called
logistic regression to predict if someone
has diabetes or not given three other
features, their weight, their
height and their blood pressure.
Using those three features are going to
predict if they have diabetes or not.
Okay,
so in this video we're going to go
over to really two key concepts.
We want to go over logistic regression,
which is a machine learning model and
we want to go over the optimization
technique, Newton's method. So we've
already talked about nudes method,
but we want to really reinforce that
idea in our head of how it works.
And the medium that we're going to use
to help reinforce that idea is this
machine learning model called logistic
regression. So before we start,
I just want to say one thing to to
really understand how logistic regression
works,
we're going to have to go over some terms
from all four or actually five pillars
of machine learning,
old,
all five disciplines that I talked
about at the beginning of this course.
Calculus, linear Algebra,
probability theory and statistics.
So actually four pillars,
not five.
We have to talk about little bits
and pieces from each of them.
So the reason I say that is don't worry
too much if you don't understand every
single detail of why
something is the way it is.
We're going to talk about
all of these concepts in the,
in the direction or in the,
in the context of learning about
logistic regression. Keep in mind,
I have entire videos coming out on
all of these subjects. So for example,
we'll talk about Matrix
transposes uh, but, and I'll tell,
I'll say one reason why we
would use a matrix transpose,
but I'm not going to say all the reasons,
but I do have a video on matrices in
general and linear Algebra coming out in a
few weeks,
right?
So just don't worry too much if you
don't understand every single detail.
There's so many mathematical
dependency chains that we can,
that we can follow conceptually, right?
When we think about these things.
But we want to have a very specific
chain of a very specific chain or bear to
specific train of thoughts because there
are so many that we can go over, right?
We only want to learn how logistic
regression works and to reinforce our
knowledge of Newton's method.
And if we do that and if we get how it
works and we're going to end and I'm
going to define all the terms
that we're going to use, right?
So you're going to get the definitions,
you're going to understand how the
equations works and work. But if,
if you don't understand every
single detail, don't worry.
I have entire videos coming out on
it and I have it all planned out.
So don't worry. Okay, so I just
wanted to say that there's,
cause there's a lot that we're going to
coat that we're going to go over in this
video. Okay. So, okay, now that I've
said that, let's go ahead and start.
So that's,
so our task is to compute is to predict
if someone has diabetes or not given
their weight, height and their blood
pressure. And this is toy data.
So we're actually going to generate
this feature, these features. Okay.
These three features. Uh, okay.
So let's start off with defining
what logistic regression is.
So logistic regression compared
to linear regression is a,
so let's compare to linear regression,
right?
So the key difference between logistic
regression and linear regression is that
linear regression, a predicts a
continuous outcome. What does that,
so versus logistic Russian,
which computes a discrete outcome.
So continuous is a means that we
can have values that range from,
um,
from negative infinity to infinity or
just an infinite possible set of values,
right? So if you have some
series, some number series,
the next value could be any,
any, you know, it could be any one
of a set of numbers out of infinity,
but for a discrete outcome, it's either
one thing or it's another, right?
We have you kind of, you box it
into some, some, some container.
So a discrete outcome would
be is it blue or is it red?
Whereas a continuous outcome would be,
um,
what is the value? What is the next value
in the series of house prices? Right?
You can have two values. It be one or
two, it can be some number between,
they're like 1.5.
It could be a number between that.
Like 1.25 and an infinitely small in that,
in that direction.
Do you see what I'm saying? It could
be an infinite number of possibilities.
And so linear aggression
is great for that.
But what if we want to predict an outcome,
like say if someone has diabetes or not?
Well that is a discrete outcome and
he's a binary outcome. Either they do,
yes or they don't know.
And so logistic regression is basically
our way of modeling a discrete outcome,
right? Uh, and so the outcome it was,
which is the dependent variable a is
going to be continuous in the case of
linear regression and discrete in
the case of logistic regression.
And so why do we call it
logistic regression? Well,
it all comes from that key function
called a logistic function that underlies,
uh,
how that underlies the model.
It is really the core
functionality of the model.
And we also call the logistic function,
the sigmoid function.
So if you've done deep learning before
or if you've done your own networks
before and it's okay if you
haven't, it's used a lot. Okay,
so this is what the function does.
Sigmoid or logistic function looks like
it's one over one plus e to the negative
x. Okay. And so why do we use e?
So, uh, so there's a
lot of reasons. I mean,
there's entire textbooks on
y e the natural number, uh,
or EULAR is number is used up.
But one great reason is because when
you take the derivative of e to the x,
uh, you're going to get either
the x again and it's the only fun,
only known function that does
this where if you derive it,
it's going to give you the exact same
results. And of course, this goes for all,
um, all versions of versions of either
the x where you can have any number of
coefficients. So five e to the ax or
three e to the x, the same thing applies.
And so the, the point of that is that it
makes it computationally convenient or
mathematically convenience,
right?
So you can see from a high level how
having a function that if you drive, uh,
did you the same value is unique.
And in that uniqueness, uh,
can help, uh, with other
computations. Okay. So, so,
right, so, so that's,
that's why we use eat.
That's one of the reasons
why we use he anyway.
He is a part of the sigmoid or
logistic function is an s shaped curve.
So given any number of values,
it's going to output a value between
zero and one and that is a probability
value. And that's what we want, right?
We want the probability that
this person has diabetes,
diabetes or they don't have diabetes.
And then based on some threshold,
like let's say it's above 70%, we could
just say, oh well if it's above 70%,
yes they have it or below.
No they don't. Right?
So we can define our threshold or we
could just outputs that probability value,
but we want a discrete outcome.
Write a Boolean, yes or no.
So that's at the heart of the algorithm.
And
so logistic regression, uh, uses an
equation as its representation. Okay?
It is an equation value, and I'm going
to show you what the equation looks like,
but the central premise of logistic
regression and when you want to use it is
when you have an assumption that
your data is linearly separable.
And that means that given end dimensions
where n is the number of features in
your data,
you could separate it linearly.
So you could draw a line that acts as
a decision boundary between all of your
data points. So in a two dimensional
space, this would be an n minus one.
So one dimensional line in
a three dimensional space,
it would be a three minus
one or two dimensional plane.
And this goes on for infinity, right?
For where n is the number of dimensions.
And so that would be a hyperplane.
So basically you're under the assumption
that your data is in fact linearly
separable.
And if it is,
then you can use logistic regression as
a way to model what the class is given
the feature set. Okay, so, so
let's, let's talk about this.
So what is the function for
logistic regression look like?
So let's say we had the following
function right here to noted by these Beta
Beta coefficients here,
right?
So it starts with Beta zero and Beta
one Beta two and then you have these
variables, x one x two. Now all
of these are our unique variables,
right? So just think of it like y
equals, well skip the why but mx plus B,
right?
And so you can,
you can have an infinitely long equation
of this forum where you can have B plus
B, three x three plus B, four x four
[inaudible] of this for. And so we're ex,
we're where B is Beta,
which these are the coefficient values,
which are the weights,
right? That we want to learn.
We want to learn what the optimal weights
are that's going to output what we
want it to output.
And so if we had this function
and we plugged in some point,
so let's just say it's this function
alone, if we were to plug in some point a,
B or x, y, whatever you want to call
it, into that is a coordinate pair.
If we were to plug it into this,
it could either give us a positive result,
it could give us a negative result,
or it could give us a a a zero,
which is a point that lies
right on the decision boundary.
So assuming that if it's
assumed that if it's positive,
it's going to be of one class.
If it's negative,
it's going to be of the other class.
And if it's zero it's going to be right
in the middle. So it's of neither class.
And so what we want is to
set this equal to some,
to some probability value
or some probabilistic value,
right? So, so we could
do one of several things.
Well one is, let me just skip this for
a second. Let me, let me go down here.
So one thing we could do is we could set
this equation not to just why like we
did with linear aggression,
but set it equal to the probability of x
given the function, right? So given this,
given this function,
we plug in the coefficients and it's
going to output a probability value.
So we could use the probability or we
could use the odds and the difference
between the probability.
And the odds is that the odds is
this is this expression right here,
which is the probability of x over
one minus the probability of x.
So note that probability of acts and the
odds of x essentially denote the same
thing,
which is the pro,
the ratio of the probability of the
event happening versus it not happening.
So why do we use the odds?
So here's why.
So given,
you know,
so given for possible values that we
could set our equation to probability the
log of the probability,
the odds,
and the log of the odds.
If we set the uh,
equation equal to,
as you see right here,
the log or logic or la la gets of the,
of the odds,
then it's going to let us
have the greatest range of
values such that it's going
to map to between zero and one.
Let me explain that.
So that means that we can have
any value for our coefficients.
So the the right hand side of this
equation right here, which is this,
this equation right here can be between
negative infinity and an infinity and
the left hand side will be equal to some
probability value between zero and one.
And so what this means is we can have
any number of values that we can use for
our coefficients.
So it allows the widest
range of coefficients to be
used for our function such
that the probability output is
going to be between zero and one.
And when it comes to reasons of why do
we use the log probability versus the
other three,
they're like the probability,
the why do we use a log odds versus just
the logs versus just the odds alone,
uh, and uh, versus the probability
versus the log probability. Well,
to sum it up, it makes it easier. Uh,
it can be extremely complicated if we
were to just use the probability alone
because we would have to, uh, fine. I set
of constraints on the regression line, uh,
for the regression coefficients
because basically, I mean the,
the log put,
getting our computing,
the log of the probability makes it easier
for us because the value is going to
be between negative infinity and infinity
for what's whatever's on the right
hand side. And there's a
lot more theory here, right?
So there's a lot of probabilistic
theory here, but let's just say like,
this is what I said at the beginning.
Let's just for all intensive purposes
of all the things that we could set our
equation too,
we're going to set it to the log odds.
We're going to set it to the log
odds and that's it. Okay. So givens,
whatever regression equation
we have on the right hand side,
we're going to send it to a log odds
and that's going to give us the optimal
relationship between any number of values
that we could use for our coefficients
and a probability value,
right?
So the general model for
logistic regression looks
like this where we have some,
uh, log odds, probably log odds on
the left, uh, and then some cof.
And then some function
on the rights, right? So,
so in this case you could say the
probability of having a disease, uh,
is p.
So we say the log probability of
having that disease over one minus the,
or sorry,
the log of the probability of the disease
over one minus the probability of the
disease is going to be
equal to our function.
And these coefficients are the
effects of the genetic factors.
And so each of these coefficients
are going to be basically tune,
these are wait values that will be
learned as we learn as we train our model.
And then these x values are going to be
the variables for those genetic factors.
So they'll,
each of those will represent one of
the features that that results in the
probability that an individual has
a particular disease. Okay. So,
right.
So,
so this whole process that we're
doing here that this whole process of,
of finding the ideal values
for the coefficients to,
uh, to, to find the
ideal probability values.
There are the ideal probability values
is called maximum likelihood estimation
or MLE.
So maximum likelihood estimation is a
general approach to estimating parameters
and statistical models by
maximizing the likelihood function.
So in deep learning we
call this back propagation.
So there's a difference here
between NLE and optimization. Okay.
So Newton's method is, is an
optimization algorithm. Okay?
So you can use this algorithm to find
the maximum or minimum of many different
functions including the likelihood
function. You can obtain ml,
you can obtain maximum likelihood
estimates using different methods.
And using an optimization algorithm
is one of them. Okay, so the,
so let's talk about the word
maximum likelihood estimation.
We are maximizing the likelihood that our
model classifies some novel data point
as the correct class. That's why we
call it maximum likelihood estimation.
We are trying to maximize the likelihood
that our model estimates or predicts
the correct class for a novel data points.
And so optimization is one technique
we could use to perform an ele.
Uh, but there are other techniques, but
we don't have to worry about that. Okay.
So like I said,
we are focused right now we are focused
on logistic regression and Newton's
method.
And we're trying to form,
we're trying to perform NLE and we're
using new method as our optimization
technique to perform an
Ellie. Okay. Um, right.
So, so why use Newton's method? Right? So
we, we talked about logistic regression,
uh, that what, what the general
equation for it looks like.
And we talked about that.
We talked about how the process of US
training our logistic regression model is
called maximum likelihood estimation.
And in machine learning or
in deep learning, it's called
backpropagation, right?
So that's why you never hear the term MLE
and deep learning because we just call
it backpropagation for supervised learning
where they are, whether it's a label,
but in general, machine
learning, the word,
the phrase maximum likelihood
estimation is used quite a bit.
So anyway, why Newton's method? Well,
it usually converges faster then
gradient descent when maximizing logistic
regression log likelihood. So it's faster
when it comes to logistic regression.
And, but the one thing to
note, and this is not a reason,
but one thing to note is
that each iteration is more
expensive computationally
than gradient descent because we are
calculating the inverse of the Hessian.
And the Hessian, and we'll talk
more about this in a second,
is a matrix of second
order partial derivatives.
And those are derivatives with respect
to each of our coefficients or each of
our weights in our function,
but it's not just the derivative of them.
That would be the Jacobean. It's the
derivative of the derivative. Okay.
And so let me say another thing. So, uh,
the Hessian is going to be
used quite a bit in this video.
Uh, and we're also going to use
some matrix terms that we're not,
that we've never used before, but we'll
learn about them as we go and yeah.
Anyway, so yeah, we're,
we're going to learn some matrix
operations as well here anyway.
So as long as the data points are not
very large, Nunes method is preferred.
It's a preferred method. So, okay.
So if we have a few data points and
we're using logistic regression,
Newton's method,
great for optimization to perform
maximum likelihood estimation.
Okay. So one more thing before we
get to the code and that thing is,
what are some other good examples of
logistic regression and Newton's method?
Remember, although the utility that
we're trying to perform is the testing,
if someone has diabetes or
not given some features,
the data is in fact generated
is in fact toy data.
And the way to improve your
understanding of this is to,
uh,
let me remove this anyway,
is to look at other examples.
So I've got one example here that uses
a psychic learn a little bit for data
preprocessing,
but more or less it's using,
it's very mathematically a legible.
So check out this one and
it does something similar
using Newton's method and
it'll just horrible Russian
board spam classification.
So that to the idea is that you can detect
if an email is spam or it's not spam.
And then the other one is click
through rate classification.
You can classify based on some consumers
clickthrough rates if they're going to
or based on their other patterns
if they're going to click through.
So you can compute the click through rate.
Anyway, these are two great examples.
Definitely check them out to improve your
understanding of both Newton's method
and of logistic regression.
Anyway, so yeah,
so that's it for our examples.
We've defined logistic regression,
we've defined Newton's
method both at a high level.
And now let's get to the code.
All right, so for the code part,
we've got our dependencies here and our
dependencies are importing num Pi for
matrix math, pandas for data
manipulation. So a lot of data,
a lot of data scientists use pandas a
lot. In fact, there's some when asked,
what tool do you use?
They'll just say does,
they won't even say python
because it's that ubiquitous.
But basically pen does is a really
popular library for manipulating data.
And what it does is it takes some Dataset,
whether it's an excel
spreadsheet or something else,
and it will put it into an object,
a native object in the, in the,
in the dependency that
is called a data frame.
And once your data is in a data frame,
you can perform a whole bunch of really
easy getters and setters on that data.
So you could specify the column and then
the row and you could delete that data,
that data point or you know,
whatever.
But it's basically very convenient
for data manipulation. Uh,
and so then we have important
warnings for error logging.
And we do have one single, very, very,
very thin wrapper on top of num Pi.
But we're only gonna use it for one line.
And I'll talk about the details
here, but basically it is a, it,
it fits our data into a matrix anyway.
Don't even worry about it
for all intensive purposes.
This is not using any, uh,
you know, heavy libraries.
It's all very thin libraries.
All the logic is going to be there anyway.
Okay?
So the first thing we're
gonna do is we're going to,
uh, we're going to define the
sigmoid function, right? So the,
the function that talks about before
that s shaped curve and what the sigmoid
function does is it outputs a
probability between zero and one. Okay?
That's it. Which is one over
one plus e to the negative acts.
So now I have this right here, this,
this, uh, but let's skip this for now.
I'm going to come back to this.
So we defined our sigmoid function,
which is that key function that is
the core of logistic regression.
We defined that function on its own,
and we're going to use a later,
but now let's define our hyper
parameters, right? And these are the,
these are in machine learning,
we call them hyper parameters,
and these are the parameters of
the model that we're building.
So the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to set the seed and the seed
is used for anytime you're using
any kind of randomly generated data.
If you have a seed, then what?
Whenever you rerun that program,
it's going to output
the same random numbers.
So why is this useful for reproducibility?
Which is good for debugging, right?
You always want the same values to be
generated so you can test your code.
So it's basically for
reproducibility for debugging.
And then we're going to define a
convergence tolerance as this very,
very small number right here.
Basically this is the minimum threshold
between the predicted output and the
actual output is going to tell our
model when to stop learning, right?
So when the difference
between our predicted output
in our actual output reaches
this threshold, then we're going
to say, okay, that's good enough.
As opposed to just saying, well, whenever
we finished the number of iterations,
we're also adding this threshold,
which we're going to call the convergence
tolerance and we'll use it and you'll
see why later. But basically it's a
threshold for when we can stop learning.
I had this other term here called
the l two regularization term,
which is going to help us regularize.
So now I'm going to go back up here
and talk about what regularization is.
So regularization is a very important
technique and machine learning to prevent
over fitting. We use it all over the
place and deep learning in general,
machine learning,
we used to everywhere.
Basically it's a technique
to prevent over fitting.
And what do I mean by overfitting?
That means when your model is to trained
on the training data and it's not going
to generalize well for new data.
So if you give it some new data,
it's not going to be able to make proper
predictions because the training data
that you tested it that you train the
data that you trained it on is too
similar. It's too homogenous. So if you
give it some very different Dataset,
it's not going to be, it's
not gonna predict that. Well.
So what regularization does is it is,
it's a technique to help prevent this.
And we have several techniques
to prevent overfilling,
but regularization is a very
popular and important one.
And so mathematically speaking,
it adds a regularization term.
So there are two types of regularization
right here that we're going to talk
about. One is called the
l one regularization and
the other is called the Lt
regularization.
So the difference is l two is the
sum of the square of the weights,
while l one is just the sum of the
weights, right? And so we have, uh, the,
the actual output minus the predicted
output and then squared plus our
regularization term,
which is the sum of the weights versus
the sum of the square of the weights
times this lambda term, which is
the regularization term. Okay.
And that's going to give us,
and what that, so adding this,
this edition is basically,
this helps our model, not, uh,
get over fit to the data. And so when
should you use l one versus l to,
well here's a list of when you should use
them and when you shouldn't. There are,
there's actually a bigger list out there,
but at a high level we are,
the reason we use it is use case
specific. So if you have, um,
if you have a small datasets and you
don't care about computational efficiency
because it's a very small Dataset,
then you would likely use l one.
Whereas if you don't,
you could use l two.
And then it also relates to
the sparsity of your data,
which means how many Zeros this does
the data have, how sparse is it?
If it's, if there's a lot of zeros
and it's very sparse. Okay. So, uh,
and there's a lot more
reasons, but basically, uh,
in this video we're going to be
using the l two regularization term.
And so anyway, yeah, so that,
so there's that. Anyway, so, uh,
we're going to use LTE regularization and
then we're going to have 20 iterations
for training. Okay. So now,
so these variables are used
to help create our data. Okay.
And so these terms come
from linear Algebra.
So the first term defines a,
the covariance between x and Z.
Covariants is a measure of how
two variables move together.
So it measures whether the to
move in the same direction,
which would be a positive covariance
or in the opposite direction,
which would be a negative covariants.
So we have two of those. And so, uh,
we want to set it 2.95.
So we have a positive a covariance.
We want these very, we want, uh,
to have our variables to be related very
closely and that would be our height
and our weight and blood pressure
can be kind of off. We're,
we're actually creating this data
right now so we can define what the,
uh, what these terms are. Whereas a
normal data, we wouldn't define it.
They would just exist, right? And then we
would have to discover these relations.
But we're defining these
relations right now, right now.
So then we have a number
of ops or observations,
which is a thousand and a thousand is
the number of data points. We have,
data points, observations, same
thing. And then we have a sigma turn,
which is the variance of the noise,
which is how spread out is this data.
Okay? So again, we're going
to get back to these terms.
We have a lot of probability to go over
in the future, but at the high level,
that's what those terms mean. The spread
of these, the spread of numbers, uh,
the relationship between two variables
and the number of data points that we
have. All right, so now we're
going to define our model settings.
So we have a set of
true Beta coefficients.
So let's just assume that we know what
the ideal coefficient should be for our
model.
Okay,
so we have those true Beta coefficients
and then we're going to have our
predicted Beta coefficients. And we're
going to s we're going to, we're going to,
uh, use the true Beta coefficients
to help us calculate, uh,
our predicted Beta coefficients.
And then we have a set of
variances for each of these inputs.
And that is how spread out
each of the inputs are.
And remember we are manually defining
these as well as our model will manually
define what our model looks like, the
shape of our model, given our three uh,
features, right x CNV, which are the
height, weight and blood pressure.
Okay.
So we've defined our model
hyper parameters and now
we can generate an organize
our data, right? So to generate this data.
Now this is assuming we don't have real
data, so we're going to generate it.
And so I'm going to introduce a few uh,
statistical terms here,
specifically the distribution,
right?
So what is the distribution at a high
level of distribution is a function that
provides us all the probabilities or
provides us the probabilities of all
possible outcomes of a
sucky castic process.
That is a process that
cannot be predicted.
A stochastic process is one that cannot
be predicted and it deterministic
process is one that can be predicted.
Okay?
So it looks like a bell curve usually.
And there's all these different
types of distributions out there.
You've got Bernoulli by no meal normal.
You have a whole bunch of different
distributions that represent all the
probabilities of a possible outcome.
For a specific outcome.
And so that's it at a high level.
And we have,
I have an entire video on
distributions coming out later,
but for now know that that's
what a distribution is.
And we're going to use a
distribution to generate our data.
We're going to use what's
called a multivariate normal
distribution to generate
values for x and z.
So we're going to use
the same distribution to
generate values for x and z
because remember they are
closely correlated height
and weight and uh, there are,
and we also define their covariance,
right, has very high 0.95.
So X and Z are very,
are very closely related.
And then the is going to be our variable
for our blood pressure and we'll,
and we'll generate that
using a normal distribution.
So a multivariate distribution,
normal district.
So we used a multivariate normal
because we had multiple variables,
x andZ and just a plain old normal
because we only had one variable it's
generated from.
Okay.
And we're going to compute what's
called the transpose of the results.
And the results of these
are going to be in a matrix.
And the transpose is when we take the
rows and the columns of the Matrix and we
flipped them right? So that, that's just
what, that's a definition of a transpose.
Okay. And that's gonna make it, um,
more neatly formatted for us for future
operations that were going to perform on
it. Okay, so we have our variables.
So let's create a pandas data frame.
Remember I said how in pandas,
a data frame is a very neat object
and neatly package object that lets us
manipulate our data very easily.
So we'll put all those variable,
all three of those variables in
our pandas data frame object.
And then we're going to compute the log
odds for our three independent variables
using the sigmoid function.
So we're going to take the sigmoid of,
let's take these three functions times
or the dot product since it's technically
a matrix.
And so just saying times,
we're going to say the dot product cause
we're multiplying two matrices together,
the Matrix of our features times or by
competing the dot product with that.
And these, uh, these ideal
coefficients that we defined before,
plus sigma, which is the,
which is the, uh, what was it?
It was the variance of the noise.
How spread out our data is times a normal
distribution between zero and one for
each of our data points.
And,
and so that's gonna give us the log odds,
which we can denote up here.
Okay.
And once we have that,
then we could say, okay, so those, that's,
those are the log odds and we want to
compute the probability sample from a
binomial distribution.
Okay.
So a binomial random variable
is a number of successes.
X has an end repeated trials
of a binomial experiment.
A probability distribution of a binomial
random variable is called a binomial
distribution,
right?
So we have some y output value and
it's going to be between zero and one.
And so we'll just compute all those
probabilities, like using this,
so randomly generated probability values.
Okay.
So then we can create a data frame
that's going to encompass our input data,
our model formula and our
outputs, right? Just like this.
So these are our expected output.
So we generated these outputs randomly,
but they are expected outputs.
So compare the expected outputs to our
predicted outputs and want to minimize,
uh, the difference between them. Okay. And
that is our learning process. All right.
And so if we were to print this out,
we would get all these randomly generated
values and notice how we don't just,
we don't just have, um, we don't just have
values for our three variables are our,
sorry, our three features. We also have
values for each of the acts and then,
uh, uh, the squared plus Z. Okay. And so,
which is all a part of our model,
our formula,
our function that we're
trying to learn here. Okay.
And so we have that now we've defined
our data and we defined what a logistic
regression is, how we optimize it,
Newton's method, we've defined our data.
And now we can have this helper function,
which is going,
which is just going to catch matrix
errors. That's it. It's not even,
I wouldn't even really need it anyway.
So now it's time for us to,
for us to learn our model and the way we
learn our model is by performing Nunes
method for optimization. And so the
way for us to perform Nunes method is,
is like, so okay for logistic regression,
here's how Newton's method works.
So recall that Nunes method
from maximizing or minimizing
a given function f of
its coefficient.
So function given the Beta
value iteratively computes
the following estimate.
Okay.
So the ideal coefficient is going to
be whatever the current coefficient is
minus the Hessian,
uh,
the Hessian of our function or the inverse
of our Hashan Times the gradient of
our function. And so that's, uh, how we,
that's the high level of Newton's
method for logistic regression. Okay.
So the Hessian,
how do we compute the Hessian of the
log likelihood for logistic regression?
The way we do that is like,
so we say the Hessian of our function
is equal to the negative transpose of n
times p plus one,
which is what x represents n
times p plus one times end times.
And a,
an end times end diagonal matrix of
weights where each of these weights is p
times one minus p times x
against, we already defined X. So,
so multiply again.
Okay.
So I know there was a lot to take in,
but that's the formula.
That's the formula for
computing the Hessian.
That's the formula for our
Hessian and then the function.
Then the formula for our
gradient is much simpler.
It's our gradient is the
transpose of acts, uh,
times a column vector minus n
vector of probabilities. By the way,
n is the number of data
samples samples we have.
And the gradient is a vector of comp whose
components are the partial derivative
with respect to each coefficient
we have in our function.
Whereas the Hessian is a
vector where it's competing,
not the partial derivative but the,
but the partial derivative
of the partial derivative.
So it's a derivative of the derivative.
It's a second order derivative.
So if you were to say, um, uh,
x cubed is your function,
the derivative would be power
rule three x squared and but,
and then the derivative of the
derivative would be six x. Okay.
So that's how that works.
And so by the way,
and so this is what, uh, that
w looks like it's a diagonal,
which is if you were to
have a matrix of values,
you would just take the diagonal of that
of p times one minus p where pure the
predicted probabilities computed at the
current value of the coefficient that
you have.
Okay.
So and so you can connect this to
something called iteratively reweighted at
least squares, but we're just not
going to do that. That's, that's,
that's for a separate time has
just for it more understanding,
but in fact I think it would be more
confusing because we haven't talked about
that right now anyway.
Right?
So to perform Newton's method,
which is a second order optimization
technique on logistic regression,
we're going to compute both the Hessian
and the gradient and we'll use both of
those values to help find the optimal,
uh, coefficients for our function.
And logistic regression is
basically on one side, it's a gem.
It's a generic regression function.
You know where you have some set of
coefficients for any number of parameter
values for any number of features or
dimensions. And on the left hand side,
you're not trying to equate it to a
single scalar that maps directly to that,
that output. But instead a probability
value that is the log odds,
the log of the probability
over one minus the probability,
and this is going to come
out to an s shaped curve.
So you can then predict the outcome of
some event or the class of what something
is going to be, which is going to be
a discreet, a single value. Yes, no,
or even multivariate, uh, or
even a multivariate output
like red, blue or green.
Okay, so right now let's talk
about the implementation here.
So we've talked about the equations. So
let's look at the code part now. Okay.
So the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to compute the probability
value.
And to do that we're going to compute
the dot product of our coefficients are
ideal coefficients.
And our w are coefficients that are,
that are to be learned,
the coefficients that we're learning.
And then we'll squash those
values with a sigmoid function.
Squashing means we're converting
them into value between zero and one.
And then we're only gonna
do that for two dimensions.
So that's why we have the MDM
NDM men equals to a parameter.
And then we're going to take the
transpose of that. And so for,
for major CS competing,
the transpose means taking the rows and
the columns and flipping them so the
columns become the rows and vice versa.
And that's just one of many
matrix operations that we do, uh,
to keep it simple right now
it just makes things easier.
It makes it more organize
and format it for,
for the next operations
that we're going to do.
We'll talk way more about
matrices later on anyway.
So that's how we compute our probability,
which is going to be an array of values.
And then we're going to use that
probability to help compute our weights,
which are, as we set
up here, right up here,
the diagonal of the probability
times one minus p. Okay.
And so we'll have that here.
And that's our weights.
Those are our weights and we'll use
our weights to derive our Hessian.
So remember this was a
formula for the Hessian.
The negative negative x x is
transpose times w times x again,
right? So in the case of
logistic regression, that's
how we compute the hash.
And you can see variable by variable.
That exact equation is then mimicked
here programmatically to compute that
Hessian. And the same case would
be for our gradient, right?
So our gradients is going to be x,
x is transpose times,
we're going to take the transpose of
backs and compute the dot product of it.
And then y minus P,
right?
We're why are predicted outputs
and then PR probability values.
And that's gonna give us our
gradient value. And this, remember,
this is all phrase single step.
So this is for a single a collection
of data points, right? And we have a,
we have to go through all
those rows and columns, right?
But there's a very single step and we
have multiple steps during training, okay?
So that's our gradient, our
Hessian, our weight values,
and our probability values, okay?
And we're going to use all of those.
We're going to use them, Paul, to
help us. Well, we, we use a Pete,
we use P to help us compute w which
we used to compete our Hessian and our
gradient as well.
But basically we're going to use both
our Hessian and our gradient to compute
what the optimal weights should be.
Right? So to compete, to do that,
we're going to take the least
square solution. Um, but actually,
so, okay, so I, okay, so we do this twice.
We do,
it's once this Newton step,
and this is basically a copy of what we
just did before, except for one thing.
And that's this line right here. Notice
how right here I have Lynn alledged. Dot.
Inthe versus Lin alledged.
Dot. Ella lst, LSTs s Q,
which is least squares.
So the reason that it's here twice
is because right now we're computing,
uh,
the,
the announced or the scalar that we're
going to use to update all of our
coefficients, but we're doing it
using the full Hessian. Right?
And so the reason that we did it two
ways is if we use the full Hessian,
it can be computationally expensive
because there's a lot of values.
But we can get around that by using a,
by not computing the full Hessian but
using a solution called lease squares.
And that's called the, so if we don't
have to compute the full Hessian,
then that's computationally
less expensive, right?
And so there are methods for doing this
and these are called quasi Newtonian
methods,
or we don't compute the full Hessian,
but we don't actually
have to talk about that.
We'll just assume that we have to
compute the full Hessian right now. Okay.
So that's what this line does.
And it uses the regularization term we
defined before to make sure that this
data is not overfit. Okay. So that's
what those into a Newton step.
And it's going to return
this scalar value,
this Beta value that we can use to update
the coefficient of our function that
we're trying to learn.
And yeah,
so then we have a convergence steps.
So remember how we defined a threshold.
That threshold is when we
want to stop learning, right?
So given our old Beta values,
our new Beta values,
and then our tolerance get
an a number of iterations,
we'll check the change and
the coefficients by taking
the difference and making
him performing absolute value because
we wanted it to be a positive value.
And if the change is greater than our
threshold and we still have less iteration
and we have, um, a certain
number of iterations still to go,
then we'll return true
or false? False. Okay.
So that's our way of stopping training.
Okay.
So then to the real meat of our code,
right?
So we'll go ahead and define
our initial set of coefficients.
And these are our wake values,
right? That we want to learn.
If they're all going to be Zeros rights
for the number of columns that we have,
which are the number of
features, or they'll, they'll,
they'll start off at zero and we'll
learn them over time given some number of
iterations and,
uh,
a boolean value that tells us if
we've reached convergence or not.
So this is our way of saying should we
keep training or not and that that's what
this is going to do. So we'll say
while not coefficients have converged.
So if we haven't reached convergence,
then go ahead and begin training using
Newton's method began optimizing.
So we'll say we'll set the old
coefficients to our current values,
perform a single step of Newton's
optimization on our data.
And once we have that,
we'll then take our coefficients and
it's going to output the updated a Beta
values. Okay. And so then
once we have our updated Beta values,
then we can increment the
number of iterations that
were going through and then
check if we've reached convergence
yet where our Beta values are the
coefficients for the model that
we're learning. And we can say, hey,
if these values are at this certain
threshold, we're good. We're done here.
Okay.
So then when we print out the results,
it's going to tell us the number of
iterations and then the Beta values over
time.
And ideally they become closer and closer
to our predefined Beta values for our
dataset.
I know that's a lot to take in,
but if you've got the basic idea of a
logistic regression being different from a
linear regression and that it's trying
to predict the probability of a certain
outcome,
not just some strict linear mapping
between x and y and that we use Newton's
method as a way to optimize logistic
regression and the w the way we compute
Newton's method is to compete the second
derivatives with respect to each weight
in our, in our function, the
coefficients, the weight values.
If you got that part, that's all
that's really necessary for this video.
There's a lot of terms that we still
have to go over a lot of probabilistic
terms like variances,
very NCS and and noise values.
There's so much more, so don't
worry about it. There's a lot,
and we're going to go over that and then
the rest of this series, so that's it.
Please subscribe for
more programming videos.
And for now I've got to Ryan Beta with
Alpha and Beta, so thanks for watching.